foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for sitting down with
Forbes oh my pleasure so you've been
named one of the most influential
Business Leaders in the Bay Area one of
the foremost impact investors on the
planet you have placed early and
successful bets on some of the biggest
companies operating today at Tesla
Farmers business Network it's quite the
entrepreneurial journey and I want to
take a step back and talk to you about
the beginning of that Journey your
father was a patent attorney and an
inventor and your mother worked on
policy is your current line of work
preordained by by who your parents were
it seems that way doesn't it and yet I
never really figured that out until a
few years ago because For Me growing up
I was one of five girls and so there was
no
gender stereotyping in terms of what
chores we did and so my father was
always inventing things in the basement
and asking for help you know soldering a
wire whereas my mother was out
campaigning for the local mayor race or
whatever and needed help Distributing
leaflets across town down that all
seemed very natural to me and and so we
as growing up we got to do a lot of
things and and bringing together their
two passions is is pretty much who I am
would you evaluate his inventions the
way you do startups today
you know it's funny because he gave us
jobs and and it when it's your father
you're not quite so liberal with uh
criticizing or and plus we were quite
quite young but one thing he knew from
the beginning is uh how to get us to to
be excited about a project like think of
the name for a new product he invented
and he would promise to take us to the
ice cream store and give us an extra
large Sunday if he chose the name of
that product if we if he chose the one
we came up with so he he had a very good
sort of motivational psychology even
though he was an engineer he understood
incentives quite well exactly but you
went on to go to college and you didn't
study Finance or accounting can you tell
me what you studied and end the first
few jobs you had out of college because
I think all of this is interesting yeah
and not only did I not study Finance or
accounting I almost didn't know what
they were and if I had I certainly
really wouldn't have liked them I was
much more of a Humanities social science
culture really interests me and and I I
actually got a Matt Masters and first a
bachelor's in anthropology which people
don't quite understand but to me it
makes a lot of sense and that that's
because anthropology really studies
behavior and culture and why do people
do the things they do what are the what
do groups bring together in terms of
language or institutions or behavior and
why does it click and when you think
about that that's kind of how you
analyze a startup this will will it be
successful What's the culture what's the
leadership what are the Norms so there
there's a there's a connection there but
it took me a long time to to connect
those dots I started very early in
public interest activities in
environmental regulation I went the day
after I graduated from college College I
moved to Washington DC I was an intern
for the Sierra Club I learned about the
role that the government can play in in
defining protection of public lands for
example and that really has been a
passion of mine for forever the nature
and our responsibility to protect it but
turning that into a job other than
interning for the Sierra Club and
working in the in that space was a lot
harder and didn't come until later in
terms of lending the finance with
with social and environmental progress
so you started on the NGO side when did
you shift to the dark side of capitalism
yeah well I what happened is I worked in
Washington I also worked at Stanford
Medical School on a on a job that
studied how Innovation happens in
medicine and what role the public should
play and helping to shape it kind of
ahead of its time in that sense and so
in it I knew I loved Innovation and why
why it worked and when it didn't but I
decided that rather than just look at it
from the government or Academia or or
the NGO I needed to learn about business
because obviously that or especially
around here in the Bay Area Innovation
was happening in the private sector and
so I decided to go to business school to
get the skills in order in order for me
to move into a private sector
orientation
I think I read somewhere that after
business school you knew you needed a
job and the traffic in the Bay Area was
one of the motivating factors in looking
for a job how did is the Bay Area
traffic what landed you in Investment
Banking
um it was one motivating factor so I
worked at Intel after graduating from
business school which was a fabulous
place it was new and and uh you know
very Innovation driven
when I got engaged to be married my
husband my husband had a medical
practice and he lived in the East Bay
and so even back then a long time ago
the traffic driving from say Berkeley to
Santa Clara was horrendous and so it is
true that I had a forcing function that
that pointed me towards a job in San
Francisco and so I even though I loved
Intel I decided that I I didn't want to
commute and so I looked for a job in in
San Francisco and this is why I became a
professional in finance just because
back then there were no tech companies
in San Francisco it's pretty hard to
believe today but what what did exist in
San Francisco were some of the early
Finance firms investment Banks Venture
Capital firms to back the the tech
Revolution and so I ended up working at
one of those Hammerton Quest were you
looking with an impact lens even then or
did that come a little later
for me the impact has always been part
of who I am but it it was expressed at
varying levels throughout my various
jobs and and never fully uh evolved
until starting the first impact fund but
what I did do for example at hmq I was
able to get a Securities analyst Analyst
job where I studied instrumentation and
reported on instrumentation stocks that
at the time were say analyzing what were
in Superfund sites so I I was able to do
something that was environmentally and
health related
then fast forward to later in my career
at h q where I turned into where I
switched to venture capital I was also
responsible at hmq for our public
affairs our political work our our
philanthropic giving mostly because no
one else was interested in it and I I
was and so that really was a way for me
to express some of the the interests in
those sectors that I didn't as a venture
capitalist and then uh finally in the
you know in the time right after the.com
uh boom and bust we raised our first
fund that combined those those two jobs
into one and that's what became DBL
Partners yeah yeah can you explain for
the Forbes audience what DBL stands for
and what it means so DBL stands for
double bottom line and by that we mean
that we invest for two bottom lines the
first is financial irr return on cash
what everyone else does the second is
where we distinguish ourselves we invest
to drive social economic and
environmental Improvement in the sectors
and regions in which we invest and so
from the get-go that's been our our
Creed we we do believe that the two
goals enhance each other that they don't
diminish one the other the other at all
and that was a fairly controversial
belief in the early days but today uh
you know almost 20 years in we're seeing
this become mainstream it's become much
more mainstream but let's go back to
when it was controversial what were
people telling you did people say you're
crazy don't do this or they just didn't
believe in the investment thesis what
was the feedback well for for one they
were very upset about their Venture
portfolios because they just lost a lot
of money in the.com
demise and so even talking about vanilla
Venture Capital was a little hard there
for a few years how however even worse
for many people was to this overlay of a
do-gooder venture capital fund that did
not compute for people and the reason is
is because back then many people
believed that if you introduced anything
other than a return on investment of
financial imperative on your investment
approach you would you would threaten
your returns if you thought of some
social outcome or an environmental
benefit it would show up as reduced
returns concessionary as we call it now
and so that that was a very common
belief we we kind of LED with the
opposite we believe there's no sacrifice
that you can do both but it was only a
belief back then and so it took us many
years to to prove that there was not
only was it not concessionary it could
be a very strong No sacrifice Financial
strategy were there certain Investments
or exits that you had in the early days
that helped you prove your case faster
sure because what you have to show
people is that when you invest in a fund
you have the idea you have the the
Acumen to make these Investments but
they have to be successful and so it
took a while it didn't happen overnight
obviously but we invested very early on
in the Solar industry we invested in a
company called power light which was
sold to sun power and it's now one of
their larger divisions we invested in
Tesla very famously we invested in
SolarCity another very strong rooftop
solar player years and years before they
were household names and so as those
companies which went through many many
problems those early days of
sustainability companies were very
difficult for lots of reasons but as
they began to succeed and grow and
develop a revenue base that was you know
very impressive and could take them
public or be acquired at a good multiple
that's when people began to let go of
some of these biases that had been so
deeply held were you the First
Institutional Investor in Tesla we were
in the First Institutional round we
weren't the only one but yeah we we were
what did you see about the company at
the time I've read that you've called it
a risky bet well part of that was
because all of my colleagues on Sandhill
Road would say things to me like what
are you doing we don't invest in car
companies this is like not Detroit what
are you doing
so there was a lot not a lot of warm and
fuzzy support for for that investment
and no one had ever done it before
really in in this region and so the
notion of how you develop a car company
that that has all of this manufacturing
and and design work and you know has
strong incumbents on the internal
combustion engine side it was daunting
um and and so so there was it was not
popular and it was very hard to raise
money for for Tesla in those early days
what's your your view on the company now
I mean Tesla is is an icon it's it's
really what's showing us how to get to a
sustainable future
seeing Elon Musk take on Twitter and
some of the other distractions would you
still make that investment
I would that for all of the the talk
about Elon and obviously there are lots
of opinions about him all over the map
you cannot deny how prescient he is how
hard working how sophisticated he is and
his view of our Collective sustainable
future is there truth to the rumor that
you told him to cool it with the
personal jet for his carbon footprint
that was a long time ago but he as usual
he's he's very uh always has the retort
I suggested maybe that wasn't great for
him to be flying around in his personal
jet a long time ago this was like before
we were public and he just wrote right
back saying uh Tesla is my carbon offset
because he was he was putting a huge
amount of his own
account to that
so that first ever fund that DBL raised
that was a little bit of a struggle
getting institutional investors on
you're being very kind it was brutal it
was brutal okay we can call it brutal
how would you compare because you closed
fund four in 2021 at 600 million dollars
compare and contrast the the closing of
each of these sure night night and day
uh and we could have we were
oversubscribed on that 2021 fund which
going back to fund one in that uh to uh
2003 2004 period we had a goal of 75
million and we just clawed our way to to
that and the reason goes back to what I
talked about a few minutes ago it just
was too new people didn't like the asset
class they certainly didn't like
something that uh combined a social
agenda perhaps with financial return and
so the big investors in fund one were
Banks who were who were able to invest
out of their CRA Community reinvestment
act uh pocket because we paid attention
to putting companies in low-income
neighborhoods if we could and so that
was something they could do and then
foundations that shared our mission to
deliver the benefits of entrepreneurial
activity more equitably across society
and now you have investors I think I saw
some Pension funds how would you
characterize the investor pool tell
people yeah so very Niche investors in
the first fund very traditional
investors for venture capital in in this
recent fund and even in our third fund
too the Pension funds uh family offices
foundations endowments some insurance
companies some corporations looks very
traditional today did you ever imagine
it getting to this point
not at all because it was such a sort of
a searing memory in in terms of how much
how many no's we got from those
constituents uh constituencies in the
first round I never dreamed that
eventually we would be able to tap into
those sources
we're speaking in a moment where there's
a lot of consumer appetite for ESG goals
and impact investing but there have been
more
state legislator proposed rules against
ESG investing this year than last year
as of the end of April it was 99
proposed state-by-state rules and it
differs state by state but that there
were only 39 last year you have Governor
Ron DeSantis signing sweeping
legislation against ESG investing
are these state laws a threat to your
business at all they're really not we're
we're more focused on impact and impact
is more oriented towards positive
outcomes as opposed to
um you know screening for negative
practices or or keeping score and so we
we focus on for example not just the
environmental benefits of the
electrification of Transportation but
the job creation benefits the ability to
put new car car plans in neighborhoods
that need those jobs so most politicians
when they actually know what we're doing
uh like that I mean because who what
politician doesn't like you know cutting
a ribbon at a new company facility so
what's your message for this current
political moment for those who might
have skepticism around ESG or impact
investing hang in there I I think that
our results are positive for both our
investors and for society and that the
politicization of this activity which
we're seeing now will pass and because
we saw that in the
2008 2009 the whole whole Solar industry
was under attack and now of course solar
is on a tear and and more more money is
being invested in Renewables now I just
read then in fossil fuels this year
you've talked about cras and investing
in areas where job creation is needed
one of the publicly available reports on
your website for investors talks about
this is where the headquarters are it's
in a low and middle income area can you
talk about why that's part of your
investment thesis and it's not just the
offsetting the carbon footprint or the
environmental good and why you're
analyzing the areas in which
headquarters are being built really goes
back to our origin story working with
the Bay Area Council and some
foundations the Bay Area council is a
leading Regional business group here and
they were getting criticized back in
thatpost.com Era for for not having even
economic development in our region and
they wanted to to make sure that
entrepreneurial companies settled not
just in the traditional Palo Alto or
Santa Clara area but in the
neighborhoods that really needed those
jobs and so that that really became one
of the things that we measured from the
the get-go and we worked with the Ford
Foundation to develop our metrics they
were one of our First Investors and it
really has to do with something that now
is is even more of a problem than it was
back then just the The Haves and the
have-nots we have a society that really
doesn't always distribute the benefits
of of technology and Innovation the way
it could and so we really do it's not
like we force people you know go site
there or go site there uh in terms of
pointing to low-income neighborhoods but
we do educate people that these are
these are neighborhoods that are worth a
try
we've talked about how you were early in
on Tesla early in on Farmers business
Network I think Pandora was an early
successful bet what do you consider your
most successful investment
well of course we always say as Venture
capitalists are our portfolio companies
are like our children and so of course
we don't have a favorite
um but and and I do think that some of
the companies we're working on now will
eventually have huge impact but in in
terms of just the the broad reach I
think that Tesla you can't really say
anything else because not only is it the
size of uh of what it what it's doing
it's the importance of what it's doing
it really is a wake-up call to everyone
on this planet that we need to do things
differently and who doesn't love cars
especially in in the United States so
it's a great way to teach people about
the importance of sustainability in
addition to being a Colossus as of a
company
on the other end what's an investment or
a company that you still think was a
good idea but didn't work out the way
you wanted maybe the market wasn't ready
or it went under is there anything that
comes to mind well of course we all have
our our troubled companies and failures
um it's good you ask because it's
important people will see that out of
these failures come come learnings and
so we had a company back in the 2008
time frame that is so what it did is so
common now but it wasn't then it was
called elephant Pharmacy and it was sort
of a whole foods for pharmacy you could
get your yoga mats and your your Eastern
medicine as well as your Pharmaceuticals
all Under One Roof and it was very
educationally oriented which uh you know
is you can get that today but back then
you know it was either go to the
traditional Pharmacy or go to a a more
of a alternative kind of a pharmacy
place or yoga studio and that so I just
I loved that company it was doing well
on its metrics in terms of same store
sales it was going to open some more
stores in the region but you know 2008
came we had a bank loan uh people it
just didn't it wasn't able to stand on
its own two feet yet because it was
still a young company and the the bank
got scared and banks of course back then
were being scrutinized by by the federal
government and so it was too risky for a
bank and even though we had a a buyer uh
the bank kind of put the kibosh on that
so that's a shame I feel like I would
use that yes and that that sounds
exactly like what I was asking something
that was a little early for 2008 but in
2023 it could have been yeah it could
have been a contender yeah exactly what
excites you about this moment in 2023
what our recent Investments or
investment Theses that you're looking at
that you think is the wave of the future
well the good news is that now Investing
For sustainability and investing with an
impact lens is very very prevalent and
millions tens hundreds of millions of
dollars being invested in sustainability
and and developing not just the capital
but the talent people are coming from
other Industries to to have this be
their signature
company that they develop that makes a
difference uh in the the the effort is
very very diverse so we're looking at
you know we're Way Beyond just solar
wind and electric vehicles although
there's still more to develop there
we're looking at things like natural
climate Solutions look when you see the
the fact that wildfires are happening
and if if wildfires were a country
they'd be number two behind China in
terms of their carbon emissions so it
isn't just the devastation of of natural
fans or homes the loss of lives it's
also the carbon footprint of our
wildfires and and the the ill health
effects and and when you actually peel
back the layers of the onion you begin
to see that while we have amazing
firefighters and and approaches to
controlling fires we don't get to them
until they've already spread in many
cases and then it's much harder to put
them out and part of that is that we
don't have the technology to marry with
the the insights that firefighters have
to to control fires and that some places
are using helicopters left over from the
Vietnam War for example and so there's
been an innovation drought we can we can
work on this you develop better tools
you don't have to have people in in
these firefighting planes all of the
time for example just like we don't
always now in Warfare we don't always
have people in the plains we're using
drones or other autonomous vehicles
goals you can get to fires in minutes if
you put together Ai and sensors and and
digest the the information available
available to you from those those kinds
of Technologies and that's interesting
so it's taking the tools of AG Tech some
of the Precision farming and AI tools
that farmers are using to grow their
crops but applying it to wildfires yeah
is there a company doing that or is that
the technology you want to see built
yeah no there are companies working on
this like the ability to perceive a fire
ahead of when it's it's going to happen
and it does come from things like
Precision AG also from the military I
mean drop it's dropping a bomb on a
place it requires all kinds of
perceiving and knowing what your target
is and so taking that military Aerospace
technology to wildfires why not do that
and so there's a company over in Alameda
for example that's called rain r-a-i-n
that's that's working on that and and
developing ties with of all sectors the
the Aerospace military industry which
would surprise me I I going into it I
didn't realize that there were some
parallel parallel activities here that's
fascinating so that I imagine is part of
what you're looking to deploy fund for
yeah and also we're looking at Logistics
the ability to deliver products
um
quickly and cheaply but also reduce the
carbon footprint figure out you know
shipping of say a artificial heart to a
patient or a various medical
applications how can you reduce the
carbon footprint of that and still save
lives what's next for DBL is there a fun
five or is it way too soon to talk about
you said you were oversubscribed well
for definitely we're we're here for the
duration we you know we're Pioneers in
this and we we feel a responsibility
just to stay with this and help the
field grow and we're having a lot of fun
I would say the current market isn't the
most fun but we've been through Cycles
before and we know that we'll we'll come
out of this one we also don't raise
funds as frequently as some other funds
do we're kind of on a four or five year
we don't put all the money out at once
and so
but in the next few years we'll be
definitely coming back when you say this
current moment isn't the most fun we are
in a tough economic cycle are you seeing
a bright light as the end of the tunnel
near I know valuations have plummeted
it's it has been tough going for Venture
capitalists and entrepreneurs alike
what's your grade of where we are right
now well I'd still give it a legacy plus
because the the capital markets the IPO
Market there's there's absolutely no
fomo on the part of the investors right
now so we do need that for for the exits
and for really developing the the
popularity of the sector however that
you know we always we we know that it
will come back so I don't get too
depressed about that and it's really a
good opportunity to teach younger
entrepreneurs to teach your younger
colleagues about what it means to live
through a cycle and that we we do need
to pay attention not just to growth at
all costs but to growth you know
sustainable if you will to to looking at
the ability to grow without raising more
and more rounds so that is a lesson
that's it's never an easy one the first
time you learn it but it's an important
one and and there was a little craziness
in in the market over the past few years
so even though I don't wish this on
anyone it it does serve a purpose it
brings the temperature down just a
little bit Yeah you come with very
valuable perspective and that's part of
why we're speaking with you today it's
for the 50 over 50. and one of the
things I'm curious to hear from you is
how
does being over 50 affect your current
line of work is it an advantage or a
disadvantage
well it's mostly a an advantage when you
have you know when you've been a founder
of a firm and you're still at that firm
uh you have a lot of flexibility and so
for me uh the ability as I was just
saying to help younger people learn
about how to get through Cycles to help
them identify what they're really good
at and help them build their careers and
move through
this cycle and understand how markets
work and when inflection points occur
all of that that's a big Advantage
because I've you know been through that
several several times I would say that
in terms of the the disadvantage
certainly and I have many many friends
in this position it isn't as easy for
older Professionals in in a down
economic climate to you know get the
promotion they want or switch jobs or
Advance their own careers so I'm very
mindful that it you know that it is
isn't um an unqualified uh easy easy
street for folks and and so I do I I do
worry about that and just in terms of
how how people end their careers or move
toward the latter part and for you know
the disadvantage I don't want to be a
Pollyanna that everything's fantastic
you know when you're over 50.
um you know certainly you you know the
the ability to have the high energy to
make sure that you're able to
um you know kind of keep at it I I think
that really is something that if you
work start working on it when you're
younger and you pay attention to
self-care and sort of keeping your your
um
your own personal life in balance that
that helps it at this at this time and
in some ways when you were you're really
busy after you're 50 your kids are a
little more independent or they're even
going to college and so
um that's another advantage
we heard from someone on the 2021 list
that they were told Venture is a Young
Person's game why are you even bothering
doing it so it's interesting to hear the
ways that you see the advantages and
disadvantages yeah well I mean of course
young people in general and I I have two
young adults as children and they you
know everyone thinks they're the center
of the universe and they're invincible
and that the world revolves around them
and so that's fine it's and there's
there's no need to kind of argue about
that but what we can lend as as people
that have you know been out there making
mistakes having successes is is
an insight for folks as to how how they
might want to do something a little
differently
we talked about how you started your
career did you ever think in your 20s
and 30s about what your career over 50
would look like
you know I didn't because and part of
that is because I was so busy
um when you are in a job like a
Securities analyst or a venture capital
in a in a in this environment in in the
Bay Area and the when I was that age and
you have a young family you're almost
like okay Petals of the metal just focus
get through day by day and so I didn't
spend as as much time thinking about
what I would do uh towards you know more
towards the end of my career I was just
getting through
um
and plus obviously I stayed at the same
firm I mean we were acquired so we
became part of JP Morgan but I was there
for over 20 years so
um I was a pretty happy camper but then
you became an entrepreneur do you
consider yourself an entrepreneur as we
sit here today I do now
um I I definitely understand the the
you know the visceral feelings that go
into founding a company and and the
difficulties as well as the enormous
triumphs you can and and successes you
can have but it was hard for me to to
get my arms around that in the beginning
because as I say I I I didn't have the
the interest I just I loved where I
worked and I didn't mind being part of a
big company so it's a it's a lesson that
um
perhaps you sh you should try things
that maybe maybe you don't think you are
because once once I made that switch I
was
you know the typical why didn't I do
that sooner really
so what's your advice for your younger
self
to to go for it I mean to to be more
open to the idea that you are more than
just the comfortable some of the parts
that you that you are at that time
shake it up a little bit
[Music]